saying something about you're going to  replace johnny knoxville  you said you're coming for his spot  that's what you say i said nothing of  the sort i i did fight pretty hard when  the contract negotiations were happening  knoxville has always been like such a  like a big brother you know and and the  jackass director jeff tremaine's always  been like this demented father figure  you know so going into that everything  that i was fighting for really what i  wanted was just for them to acknowledge  like hey you know stevo for the last 10  years you [ __ ] worked you've been  killing it and i wanted just that  acknowledgement scratched that itch it  didn't get me anywhere he bled you know  i'm glad that i don't have to spend the  rest of my life wondering what it would  have been like to fight for myself and  now i know i can't take anything away  from knoxville or dickhouse and i'm glad  that i tried to fight for myself i'm  happy that i had the experience